four and 20 this year they blew a lead  against the lakers in indiana  but here's a wide open three in and out  the bonus doesn't have the lift  but he have 10 000 rebounds for the king  as he got that board carmelo  but indiana's got the miss  so lebron 10  000 career rebounds  rick carlisle stands up and tells his  team settle down a little bit and the  vert turns it over as they try to rush  it and they foul lebron  [Music]  how about the only player stu  in the history of this great game  over 30 000 points 10 000 rebounds and 9  000 assists now that's saying something  when you're the only player this has  nothing to do with being the youngest to  this or quickest the quickest or  whatever the case he's the only player  in the history of the game